[Music]
all right so I already mentioned this is
the third one in our sparkly are serious
and we we're gonna be covering different
topics for this webinar first of all
we're gonna start us with an overview as
we always do and we're gonna close up
with questions but really we're gonna
cover three topics in the webinar the
first one is about scaling our we'd new
sparkly our function that we introduced
in sparkly our oh six called spark apply
edgar already on the first webinar he
gave us an intro to these this function
we're going to get into the details of
how it works in in a more deeper way
second topic we're going to briefly
discuss levy which is a service that can
run together with an app apache spark to
make us be able to connect from our
desktop environments to levy and spark
services and the last topic that we're
gonna consider today is building
applications that you'd use the spark
with shiny and sparkly are with outlets
let's get started with our us and as i
mentioned this is the third in the
series of webinars if you are starting
with this webinar I highly recommend you
that you also take the intro webinar I'm
not gonna cover everything but if this
is your first webinar in the in the
series that you're starting with all you
need to know is that apache spark is a
cluster computing environment it's
independent from storage so definitely
you can have your data and effort in
different data sources that spark will
enable you to compute against and
sparkly are is the topic of this webinar
which is our package it's just an hour
package like any other
package in the crown ecosystem and it
enables basically connecting us from our
into Apache spark on the on the second
webinar we briefly discussed how to
create extensions we went over how to
use first of all how to use extensions
how to use our code to extend
sparkley are into order functionality
that is not core from the package we
also took a look at writing Scala code
to really take advantage of 100% of the
functionality available in SPARC and
finally creating our packages that can
as well be published to the cran repo
and definitely another another
interesting series if you're looking
into topics like using h2o graphics or
connecting to multiple data sources now
for this webinar we're gonna focus
mostly on spark and sparkly are but
we're gonna take a look at one data set
that is a little bit more interesting
that what we've been doing in that we
did on the previous webinar these data
set it's called the common crawl project
and is basically source of web pages
that this organization has already
provided it's a pretty big data set
where and in order to be able to extract
information out of these data set what
we really need to take into
consideration is how to scale our
computations to be able to access the
data and both process it so we're gonna
be talking in detail about this and
we're also gonna mention that we're
going to talk about levy as a way of
connecting to a spark from your desktop
computers and last but not least how do
we build shiny applications using
sparkly are and again since sparkly R is
an our package you can use sparkly R
with any of the other existing packages
in the our community and is
Chinese is definitely a good match but
you can also consider using for instance
sparkly are with our markdown and other
packages to really create compelling use
case as well using Apache spark with
with our so first topics scaling are
first of all I want to mention kind of
like what is the motivation for using
our directly are while you're scaling
your computations right so you know
you're always using our code while
working with sparkly are through tools
like the plier or the ml leave grabbers
that's partly our support but there's
cases where you might want to use the
actual art code running at scale on your
cluster so there's there's kind of like
to use cases that I currently see on for
first Park apply so the first one is the
example that we have on the top and
really what it what it's talking about
here is you know a lot of you are
experts on our and it's what spark apply
provides is a way of leveraging our
current skills with our in in spark so
for instance suppose that we have the
Irish table and we want to we want to
push we want to change the table to
contain some jitter and you know if
you're familiar with our you might be
also familiar with the jitter function
now there's there's a way of doing this
in spark I'm sure but you know like on
top of our heads might not really
remember what it's what is exactly the
function signature etc right we're just
familiar with our and we want to use the
tools that we know and love so in this
case what we can do is run over the iris
spark table have we previously copied
into spark we can run spark apply with a
custom function and what is important
here to notice is that on the right side
the S apply from
that is applying their jitter function
over each column this is this is our
code right this is called code that
we're familiar with and in our code that
is executing across across the cluster
so very easy kind of like entry point to
reuse the skills that we already know in
our and the other the second use case is
basically as a way to complement our by
this what I mean is that spark is a rich
ecosystem where you can do a lot of
things but there's still a lot of
packages on the our community that
provide a lot of value right and and for
instance one case is that at times you
might want to run a linear model linear
regression over over spark and Emily or
h2o might be just what you need in some
other cases you might want to use the
actual linear regression for a subset of
the data that that would match better
the expectations that you have from from
the model that is created so for that
that particular case you can act you can
also use the spark apply in this case
we're using the Broom package to tidy
the linear model that we're creating but
the linear linear model that is being
executed it's exactly the same linear
model that you would run in our it just
happens to be the case that is being
executed over data set that it's large
enough that it's worth splitting into
smaller pieces so we're running a group
by query here over the species which
means that basically we're asking spark
to split the data set into groups by
species something worth noting in this
in the concept of spark apply is that
the function that you provide it's gonna
it's gonna the the parameter that it
gets which is is a data frame and the
result of this function that spark apply
expects should be also a data frame
I don't think God we definitely got a
bunch of questions of like a spark apply
is not working appropriately and a lot
of them were mostly related with not not
returning the correct correct data type
which is should be should be a data
frame from all the functions that you
cried on spark apply so those are our
two main use cases and but what I want
to talk a little bit is give you an
overview of how spark apply actually
works so this diagram shows how your
spark cluster probably looks like today
if you're already on sparkly our user
and our user what you should probably
what you're probably doing today is you
have a machine which is usually your
gateway into the cluster that might also
be the master node of fergus cluster
that basically has are they are runtime
installed and where you are already
using spark we are and several other
packages from this machine it is usually
the case that our studio or shiny shiny
server would be installed on this
machine so you know kind of like this
this is this this would be Al a diagram
that looks familiar to you with with the
reuse on your day to day so the first
important thing to understand for spark
apply is that it requires a change in
your cluster and by this what I mean is
that you well it is there your
responsibility
sparkly are want to help you with this
particular step to install are on each
worker node this this is usually a
pretty straightforward step there's
usually you know in my in my demo for
instance I provisioned this my cluster
with script and basically I just had to
add one more line to say hey when you're
provisioning this cluster make sure that
are is installed in each worker node but
it's important to notice because if if
you have a cluster that looks more like
this you won't be able to use spark
apply
it is the case that you will be able to
use any of the sparkly art functionality
that you already know and are familiar
with but if you want to use the spark
apply you need to get our installed on
each worker node and this really depends
on each different different clusters
you know require different ways of
installing are on each in each node
service providers like for instance data
breaks already support you know
execution of our codes across their
cluster so you wouldn't you wouldn't
have to to worry about this so the next
step is okay what happens when we
actually run spark apply so you would
you run spark apply from our studio and
in this case we're running the same same
function that we that we looked at which
is just using jitter to add some noise
into our data set and what happens there
is on the first call well the first time
that a worker node needs to make use of
this distributed functionality
what sparkly are with spark are gonna do
is they're gonna deploy all your
packages that you're currently using to
each worker node so just to be clear
here you don't need to ask your system
administrators to manage packages while
you're using a spark apply spark apply
will do that for you while you're
executing in this case you know pretty
small closure would basically deploy all
those packages for you to each each
worker node it does take a little bit of
time we'll see an example of these it
depends on your cluster but it's not bad
and you get basically all the
functionality the rich functionality
that you would expect to use in our on
each each of the worker nodes and then
well last but again not least your code
is gonna be executing over each worker
node so in this case again is the healer
function what each worker node is gonna
get is this this code with a subset of
the data set the way spark works is
based on
the partitions so whenever you get a
partition that is basically a set of
rows on your data set we are going to
apply the function that you give us to
spark we are in each in each node and
then spark will collect the results and
put them back all together for you so in
general this kind of like covers how
spark spark apply works and definitely
if you have questions please write them
down and we'll will address them the
next the next part that I want to touch
base on is taking a look at a real world
example of using spark apply with a
decent data set right and I mentioned at
the beginning of this webinar that the
common crawl is a very interesting
project because basically it's what it
does it it is it downloads a lot of web
pages into a common data store so you
could potentially do this same exercise
with our web scraper but it would take a
really long time right because you need
to do the work of actually retrieving
each web page by yourself and that that
that takes even more resources and
that's much more complexity so instead
what we can do is use this data set
which is called the common crawl for for
this particular demo I wrote a library
called spark work that basically reads
these files called work files and that's
that's the type of file that is stored
in these in this project to my knowledge
there's no parser of work files on one
spark and the file itself it doesn't map
well to existing file formats it's not
you know it's not that we can use like a
CSV reader or things alike I'm sure that
you can hack your way into using
existing tools as well but it it was
like a interesting data set and also
file format to consider to doing our own
parsing because there's there's always
gonna be edge cases where you have to
write your your own extensions in order
to process data but he is
domain-specific
so this library is part work uses two
interesting features one is spark apply
and the other one in this case we can
use any package so the package that I
chose to parse these files is our CPP
and it's interesting because obviously
our CPP brings a lot of computation
power and it's very very efficient and
you can see here the code we won't get
into the details you can you can you can
take a look at the github repo if you're
interested but it's not a lot jisub is
less than a hundred lines of our CPP
code and then the helper function that
parses well that that provides this
functionality for our it's also not that
big so you know definitely definitely
for those of you that have particular
parsing they need to parse files is
something worth worth considering so I'm
gonna switch to this cluster this is a
cluster that I literally provision a
couple hours ago I saved us a little bit
of time by you know starting the cluster
before this webinar you can see that
there is about 50 nodes in this dis
cluster so definitely gives us some good
sense of how these works at scale and
you know what what I the way that I set
up this cluster was basically following
the diagram that we saw on the couple
slides ago on this webinar right where I
basically you have our studio installed
in one of these in the mail in the
master node and that's where I'm gonna
do all all my day-to-day work analyzing
data yeah so the first interesting thing
to do here is to connect so I already
run these lines for us and basically the
interesting thing here is that think
we're using young client mode we want to
connect us yarn client sometimes for
demos we use master equals local because
get helps us get faster up and running
but in this case definitely we wanted to
take advantage of the cluster
then the next interesting thing is
basically I we're gonna we're gonna see
the result of executing a very simple
function across the cluster as I
mentioned this cluster has 50 nodes and
each node has eight CPUs so I wanted to
take full advantage of these and I
executed this line if we go if we go to
this part you I what first first of all
what is worth noting is that you know
you should see all your worker nodes in
this this cluster and then the
interesting thing here is that the first
spark apply call that we run it was this
one number zero you can see that it
actually took one point three minutes it
took one point three minutes even though
the function is pretty simple
he's just counting the rows and this is
the one time cost that I was mentioning
that spark apply requires well as you
start processing data in your cluster
basically what you would see here when
we zoom in is that a lot of the time in
for this particular job was spent on
tasks deserialization time this is
basically spark using copying all day
all day all your package package
dependencies in a distributed way across
all the nodes and you can see that for
the most part this is this is a parallel
process and it runs pretty fast for the
amount of machines that we have if we
were if we were to run these one more
time
again running these again on the cluster
and you can see that it's pretty fast
probably took about two seconds
yeah and mostly since since the cluster
has already been initialized you can
make full use of your packages without
without any any any overhead anymore all
right so the next the next call that
Iran is basically reading reading data
from the common Crowell project and in
this case since we have 50 times 8 we
have 400 notes we were able to read 400
files from this project each file has
about 3 gigabytes so we're about we read
about 1.2 terabytes of data and you can
see the result of this job here
basically it took about six point six
minutes to read these 1.2 terabytes
it scales very nicely a number of nodes
so if you wanted to actually reach the
seventy two terabytes I believe from
this data set you could throw machines
in and you know be able to process this
data yeah and you kind of like to give
you a sense of how an efficient job that
is making use of your resources looks
like you can take a look at you know the
graph right where you see that a lot of
the workers are executing the job right
so now that we have our data set loaded
what can we do well one of the things
that we can do is count the number of
tags and spark the spark work library
kind of like gives us these parsing
statistics by default and we can see
that from all the web page web pages
that we process on these 400 files we
found about like 36 billion tax if we
count the number of lines that we found
out which most roughly matches the
number of web pages that were processed
we can see that
about 10 10 million West pages one thing
to notice is that what I'm what I'm
interested in extracting from this
dataset was the keywords tag from HTML
so this for those of you that do web
development this might look very
familiar for those of you that are not
familiar with web development basically
each web page in the in the web has well
no it's not required but a lot of them
have attack that helps search engines
and other other consumers of your web
page explain what your web page is about
so you're gonna see this tag on a lot of
web pages it basically says hey this is
a meta tag it contains keywords and then
inside it it basically contains a comma
separated list of key word values that
describes the webpage that you're
browsing to you so what we want to do is
we want to split this this tag extract
the tag and split it by commas such that
we get like a nice hopefully tidy table
of how these data looks like and I it's
really has already run you can see here
that wasn't that bad
on performance wise and we can take a
quick look first of all like how many
how many keywords we have total we had
about 10 million pages and you can see
that you know we have about 85 million
keywords so it seems to be the case that
our I mean there's there's roughly about
880 keywords per per web page on average
right some something around those lines
and you know this is definitely pretty
interesting already results for out of
you know processing all these data what
I want to what I want to mention is that
usually what you want to do when you
when you get to this point where you
have processed a significant amount of
information that you might want to reuse
later
or share with colleagues and with other
tools you might want to graduate a
Sparky file and we're going to use this
functionality later in this webinar but
basically what I'm doing is this table
of keywords that we found we're also
grading it on disk across across the
cluster sake words table we can take a
little a look at some of the keywords
that we found so for instance if we were
to look at all the web pages that
contain the keyword the keyword math and
we were to get for instance in this case
what we're doing is just getting all the
pages that have that and you know like
if then we're basically just getting the
keywords that are related to pages that
have the math math keyword in it some
you know here are some of the ones that
are related this one's is it's this set
is not ordered so you know like there's
definitely you know like there's some
more popular ones here like geometry and
math definitely you would see those two
keywords more correlated than other ones
but yeah so this this kind of like
completes what what you could do on
while exploring data sets with spark
apply we're definitely used again this
data set but first I want to talk a bit
about levy so so what is levy leave is a
service that enables you to connect to
to Apache spark remotely in our in our
in this in this demo in this cluster
we've been using our studio directly
from from the cluster so that means that
you know we need to connect into the
cluster or make the cluster available
you can always have obviously great
authentic ation through our studio into
your cluster which is a great way of
setting up your cluster and so some
other cases you might be either limited
or you might have a need to use spark
from your desktop machine the way that
you would do this is kind of like a
two-step process first you would have to
also eat ask
your system administrator or to provide
levy
in your cluster some clusters especially
provided by cloud providers already
support living I know at that at least
microsoft azure supports levy by default
inner clusters but there there might be
others that provide provide levy as well
by default and if not it can always be
installed this its couple lines it's
basically a download of a zip file and
then the configuration and starting off
the service once you have that ready up
and running connecting is pretty
straightforward I highly recommend that
you set up authentication with levy
especially since it runs over HTTP which
is basically a website that anyone you
know that has access to these cluster
would be able to enter write so highly
highly recommended that as part of
setting up levy you also set up
authentication with levy but once you
have that set up you can basically just
run spark connect with the address and
levy so in this case we're not gonna run
through through the whole connection but
I do want to show you how these would
look like if you're using the latest
version of sparkly art which I also
highly recommend and what you could do
is as long as you're using our studio
there's two you preview 1.1 which you
can you can download from our previous
site you can basically set the address
to your levee service the port is not
gonna be 87 87 this is the port from our
studio
I believe the default is 89 89 for levee
but that's something something that your
system administrator can can give you
same for username and password and you
know you can you can connect and
basically this is this a desktop version
of our studio and you would get
connection to that that remote cluster
as well alright so to
cover our last topic in this webinar
we're gonna we're going to talk about
shiny and well you definitely some of
you are probably more expert than what I
am on on shiny building applications
with shiny but there's a few things that
I want to cover that definitely you want
to be aware of as you build applications
in shiny that you spark we are and this
is a little bit technical but again you
know it's not that bad
what we're looking what what we're
looking at on this diagram right is one
of the functions that you probably are
familiar with in sparkly are called
table cash what this function does is
basically creates memory you know loads
into memory into memory your table
persisted well under storage in sparkly
alright so usually this operation takes
a long time right like if we when we
were working with the common crawl data
said if we were to run table cache on
the original data set it would basically
have to read everything right and that
would take some time so underneath the
covers what happens is as users we run
table cache underneath the covers
sparkly R is connecting to Apache spark
through a socket and this operation is
synchronous meaning that it will have to
wait until things complete to continue
so we run table cache part of the
operation
you know like starts triggers the
caching functionality on Apache spark
but then when we try to complete this
what as this code is trying to finish
complete completion it's gonna lock and
that means this is good while you're
working with in a single user
environment right like you don't want to
cache a table and you know like then
work with something that hasn't finished
caching so this is this is good behavior
that we want
it's basically caching and the comment
is not gonna finish into your caching
finishes right and it
respect this is this is pretty obvious
that's that's the way we want operations
to work now so to consider a couple
cases if you have a single user using
SHINee you know it's it's all great
right
you know whenever whenever you do an
operation and shine on shiny that is a
sparkly are well you know the operation
is gonna it it's got you you're gonna
get the results you kill that operation
finishes and you know the faster the
operation obviously the faster the
results you're gonna get so let's
consider that case if you have fast
applications and sparkly are and you
have more than one user so what is going
to happen is that when if if both users
are trying to use shiny functionality at
the same time that both used this spark
application basically since we are
blocking for sparkly our operations user
one will come in do an operation the the
operation takes say two seconds well the
second user getting you know working
working with this application will have
to wait for the first user to complete
this operation that's that's the default
behavior especially when you're using a
single hour process so in order to fix
these these you know behavior the
easiest way to go is to basically assign
multiple our processes to it one our
process to each user and this is this
functionality that is very easy to
enable on our shiny server Pro so
definitely definitely worth considering
while working with sparkly our
applications so once you enabled one
hour hour process per user basically you
know each user is going to have their
own art process and when the second user
comes and triggers the spark application
you you won't you won't have to wait on
resources except for you know if if if
the star cluster is busy right but um
yeah definitely
definitely worth knowing about this it's
something that you won't experience
while building your shiny application
but
definitely something that you want to
consider specially when when you deploy
your application now taking taking a
look at a quick example work
transitioning an application from using
from using shiny to using spark is
actually pretty straightforward this
this I believe is the HelloWorld
application that you know you you get by
default when you're using shiny and
finishing styling shiny there are a
couple things that you want to change
either on the global on start function
you want to make sure that you learn you
load sparkly R and you connect to your
cluster this this is a simple example
we're connecting to local and then we're
copying the faithful table the faithful
table into a spark so that's that's part
of the setup and then the order line
that I had to change to make this work
with sparkly R was line 27 where we
actually filter these data set
instead of used instead of filtering a
data frame and I would now we need in
this case we're using the plier by
pulling the wait time and that's that's
pretty much it the rest of the
application is exactly the same so how
does this look like with our with a
cluster that we have up and running yeah
so some of the first the things that you
want to do is well for for testing
purposes and while you're building your
application you can do it directly on
your on your our session if you were to
deploy the application that you're
building you wanna you want to you want
to follow the patterns that we recommend
for building applications right so you
will want to deploy your actual
application in your shiny server
directory and there are other thing to
consider is if once you deploy it you
would also need to assign permissions to
your to the user of your shiny service
which one fold is shiny you will have to
sign it also HDFS permissions to have
access to the cluster so in this case
it's a little bit simpler because we're
we're just going to run the shiny
application directly from from our
our interface right so for instance what
we were what we want to do is we want to
build a small app that makes use of
these keywords that we have produced as
part of crawling these data set or
retrieving these data set so I have a
very simple text box somewhere in here
Oh another one this is the text box and
we have a plot and for plotting the
related keywords or I'm gonna use they
we're using the word cloud package and
then on on the server it's it's it's
basically where I'm sort of like almost
copy pasting they deploy or query that
we use to explore some of the keywords
so let's take a look at what we're doing
so where we're getting the keywords from
the text box we're splitting them this
is this has nothing to do really with
with with sparkly arrow spark but once
we have this list of keywords I'm I'm
we're gonna run operation with progress
saying that we're executing something
under spark and we are going to perform
like a similar query where we're
basically getting all the web pages that
contain that keyword and then we're
gonna join them with a with the same
table to get the full list of keywords
we're going to group by keyword and
we're going to count them and then we're
gonna filter well we're just gonna
remove the keyword that we added because
obviously it's containing no webpages
and then we're just gonna arrange the
the keywords top to bottom to see which
are the most common ones and we're gonna
get the top Towson and then we're gonna
collect the result so we're only
bringing 1000 rows of data back to our
and this is important because you don't
want to run you don't want to run you
don't want to retrieve a significant
amount of data back to your main node
right right now we're running on 50
nodes so it's definitely not possible to
bring all the data back so we need to be
conscious when we plot or when we
explore results to only retrieve the
data that we are interested in and that
fits in today into the current our
process and
yeah the last step is to run these word
cloud over over over there the data that
we retrieve word cloud would take the
key words and the count so that's that's
pretty much it so I'm gonna run it
locally and we can we can play a little
bit about with this before we go into
questions all right so this is this is
our shiny application on behind it it's
running on spark so we're gonna see here
we see that we have the last job was the
job 27 so let's just start with
something like legislature for
statistics and basically what's
happening under the covers is we're we
should see a job running here which
already completed its job 28 and when we
back when we get back basically all the
keywords associated with statistics that
we found in these data set it's gonna
zoom in a little bit probably the things
that you would expect maybe not I don't
know for improbability answers help
algebra and there's definitely some
somewhere if just for fun mostly if we
were to use stats instead of a
statistics the keywords might be pretty
different of what we find in the web for
instance in this case NBA's one that
seems to be closely correlated with
stats you know and fantasy soccer player
that's it all right its course and you
know we can we can take a look at order
order keywords right and you know you
know you were to look for superheroes or
why not
would you get a good sense of what what
the keywords are associated with them
books resources Batman associated with
Superman
Avengers Wonder da Vinci and now the
cool thing to notice here is that you
know we basically you know we're able to
get get us up and running in literally
one hour of
compute time I mean I set up the cluster
a little bit earlier but um basically
you can run these with one hour of
compute time with 50 nodes we can you
can run about one one point two
terabytes in this case but you can also
scale it for more because it is not
astronomical at all you know it's less
than the cost of going out for lunch in
a lot of places and you can see here
that we're recording
according all day well a subset of the
data set that we created which is the
key words in a pretty responsive
responsive way that's good let's get
back and closed up here so we've covered
shiny and sparkly R so we have the
basics of how to build these type of
applications interesting resources for
this webinar definitely you know we've
been recommending going to Sparta our
studio comm you would find more
information about SPARC apply in this
website a website that you're obviously
familiar with if you want actually to
download shiny and you want to configure
it and find the admin guy and all that
administration guide shiny dark sitcom
for all Apache will Apache levy related
questions are currently on documentation
currently levies under Apache as an
incubation project so you can go to levy
dot incubator dot apache dorg and read
more about it and how to configure it
appropriate appropriately and obviously
if you have any if you find any issues
in any of these topics or you have you
finally find yourself with a question
that hasn't been answered on star
coverflow by the community you can find
us on github on our studio with under
sparkly are so that's what we have
definitely you know we have have or most
of this partly our team in this session
so if you have questions that are
related to this webinar or even if we're
not if time allows us we can we can try
to address as many questions as possible
and if not definitely reach us out on on
github and we'll follow up
it seems that we have well of you okay
let's see what is the right ones I think
they are let's see question about sport
yeah okay I see here I see that Xavier
is using LM does this mean we can't use
normal or machine learning packages with
spark apply instead of using of instead
of just relying on Emily
so here clear the quick answer is yes
and no you know like there's there's no
automatic way of paralyzing an algorithm
that was greeting for running in a
single computer to make it to outer part
to make it automatically parallelizable
into multiple computers right so
basically dance so even though you can
run machine learning on each machine it
doesn't mean necessarily that you can
run at scale on a machine learning
algorithm that has already been written
you are now there's there's interesting
ways of doing this right for instance in
the example that we looked at a lot of
this a lot of times you don't need to
run a linear model across your entire
data set you might have to run a linear
model across many medium sized data sets
right like for instance if if you were
to be if if you were to doing
predictions per CD for your company you
can you can partition your data say that
you have like a thousand series you
could partition your data by city and
then run any machine learning that you
already are familiar with in are per
city at scale across your cluster so
that would run really fast cuz it's
running across your cluster however if
you had to run this prediction across
all your cities right and that this is a
data set that doesn't feed like then the
answer is no there's an interesting user
talk that you can look read about is
called the title I believe is software
alchemy when one of our users explores
aggregating machine learning models that
were independent independently computed
such thing with especially for models
that have the property
what where you can sort of average the
results and I believe in his talks he
mentioned that in some cases you can do
that with linear linear regression where
you could potentially run linear
regression across multiple partitions
and then sort of like aggregate them but
but this is like a little bit more
advanced I think I think in general the
answer is no it's not you won't be able
to automatically run these models at
scale unless you partition the data
which it does happen in a good amount of
cases but not you know have you guys
tested the performance against any other
packages that allows to connect to spark
well I mean this is this a pretty broad
question right and yes so we've we've
done this in different areas we haven't
done an exhaustive performance test
across every single function because
that would be too time-consuming but for
instance comparing sparkly R with spark
our on connection times we're at a power
when when I run these data set I
actually also I run the same I also run
this same parsing of the spark work
files using pure Scala code and it was
taking roughly about the same time and
yeah so we take it in a in a case by
case basis so we don't have like a
comprehensive you know performance
benchmarks across everything but
definitely when when something is
interesting or when someone raises this
question a question for a particular
function we try to take a look and do
due diligence to be as fast as any other
any any other not just package but also
any other technology like Scala Titan
while working with spark oh I think the
question does anything exists or are
there plans to have a helper that will
spin up spark EMR cluster for us giving
our AWS credentials ah yes I would
really like that but it's honestly not
that bad we don't have any particular
plans to do this what I would recommend
is if you search for for that particular
question sparkly are an EMR
and there was a blog post from the
Amazon AWS team and this the script that
I run is basically this script they they
run they have a script called our studio
sparkly our EMR five dollar sage and
basically when you provision you know in
your your AWS EMR console when you
provision this cluster you can add a
bootstrap action in this case I'm using
my my own script because I modified it
up which use the latest version of our
studio by default but this one actually
runs pretty well so yeah but I mean that
to answer your question is no we don't
have any any plans that I'm aware of
I think it would be nice but you know
the existing the existing solution is
not that bad I mean it's not honestly
you know it's copy paste and you get
your cluster up and running but yeah I
would be nice to say awesome
sometimes can you elaborate of why we
should porque oh I totally forgot about
mentioning that yes so you so in the
demo in this demo like I actually didn't
end up you know like reading back from
perky what what I would say is what I
wanted to say doing during our demo
there is that a lot of times you know
like the closer that you use for
computing your initial you know
understand understandings of your of
your data like might be much bigger than
the cluster that you need to share your
data in you know start you know shiny
application so what I wanted to mention
there is that a lot of times what makes
a lot of sense is to use a pretty big
cluster for the initial computation of
data and then you can scale back the
cluster within for with the data that
you're that you actually need for
running your shiny application and then
load it back from from Parque sorry
about that I feel like it wasn't very
clear why we were sitting at us as poor
kid but I'm definitely you know like it
makes sense to you know especially if
you're gonna be disconnecting from the
cluster and switching switching to an
application that is running 24/7
you know like you don't need that fool
closer where you did your initial
analysis and saving to parquet I'm
loading it but from parquet is usually
the steps that you follow or that I you
know that I would recommend following
for your aspera complication I don't
know if I have have the code well we're
gonna make the code available in the in
the webinar we're in our repo but uh
here here here is a part that I was
mentioning I didn't run this this line
because basically I'm using my existing
existing session but if I were to
recreate the cluster with smaller nodes
and share these with my colleagues the
data said I believe is only something
like 10 gigabytes or something like that
for this particular case so it's still
great to have it in memory for fast
responsive queries but you could load it
basically from park' once once you start
your shiny application directly on your
your deployed server that was the point
of it and sorry about that
so it's per K better than caching sorry
about this again yeah so well it depends
right and also is there a quicker way to
cache using spark we are well the
fastest way to cache would be to put it
in memory and that's that's still
desirable for a lot of cases right even
when we try to park a you would want to
cry it load it back into memory to get
fast responsive times with with shiny
applications but no I mean I think in
general port K is not better than
caching except for cases where you don't
have enough memory right so definitely
you know if you don't have enough memory
to cache all your data saving your your
results as a park a file also makes a
lot of sense right because it would save
you computation but in this in this
particular example and again the point
was that if you're turning if you're
moving these to more of app if you're
building this application to share with
your colleagues for this particular case
you don't need to recompute everything
all the time you want to save it as a
park a file then loaded in memory each
time that they each time that the shiny
application each time that the shiny
server starts for the first time they
shiny application and then you're you're
good to go
all right well thank
so much I believe that was the last
question thanks again everyone da da
[Music]